there's been years and years of talk by
presidents about making our children
safe again in their classrooms this
president is determined to finally get
it done people sitting in my position
did not take action they didn't take
proper action they took no action at all
we're gonna take action we're gonna do
strong background checks we're gonna
work on getting the age up to 21 instead
of 18 we're getting rid of the bump
stocks and we're going to be focusing
very strongly on mental health mr. Trump
held another sit-down on the subject at
the White House today this time with
state and local officials from across
the country in addition to gun law
reforms and mental health screenings the
president suggests arming some teachers
to doterra school shootings we have to
harden our schools not soften them up a
gun-free zone to a killer or somebody
that wants to be a killer that's like
going in for the ice cream that's like
Here I am taking one of the fake news
network CNN last night was saying I want
teachers deaf guns I don't want teachers
said that I want certain highly adept
people people that understand weaponry
guns if they're if they really have that
aptitude I think a concealed permit for
having teachers and letting people know
that there are people in the building
with gun you won't have in my opinion
you want to have these shootings because
these people are cowards they're not
gonna walk into a school if 20% of the
teachers have guns not everyone is on
board with that idea so a lot of uh
progress in terms of the last two days
getting people together Greg to talk
about these issues brainstorming coming
up with some ideas the president now has
some specifics that he sees too seems to
be seizing upon you know it's
interesting that most of the practical
solutions are coming from reasonable
people people that know statistics
understand the weaponry and could speak
rationally I have to say that we've gone
through this a lot a lot of these
shootings in the last especially with
the five over the last six years we have
mentioned specifically these very
solutions we've talked about hardening
soft targets I remember
there's a shooting I would say the same
thing about Fox News has we're
surrounded by security and the people
that talk about gun control on TV are
surrounded by security when you're on
CNN or MSNBC or wherever there are
people who create a loop of fabulous
armed security so they can go tell you
why you shouldn't have a gun we've
talked about databases we've talked
about asylums a number of times I guess
my point is it amazes me how narrow the
media is on this topic that they act as
if they've never heard these things
before that these are all like
mind-blowing oh my god you mean how have
armed security in schools where you're
criminalizing the schools it's like no
it's like this these are not new ideas
yeah but these are ideas that we have
talked about and it drives me crazy it
just shows when anchors and people get
the vapors over this stuff it shows how
blind they have been to this discussion
and now they've cordoned themselves off
from people with actual sensible ideas
instead of saying do something and then
getting angry and pat emotional these
are actually practical solutions but we
have talked about these for years years
okay Dana what do you make of the you
know I guess the last thing of 48 hours
in terms of the discussions the people
that came to speak groups brought
together and the ideas well I I think
it's all been super interesting and I
was thinking about today this talk about
the presidents cuz I think the CNN Town
Hall isn't just something different and
it was a different tone and tell a bit
later you know that one of the things
that you do at a White House I think
they still have it there it's called the
policy time with the president this is
usually something that is definitely not
on camera and it's where everybody that
has a seat at the table usually senior
staff and relevant federal agencies
either the secretary or the deputy are
there and they throw out their ideas and
the president can say yes no I don't
like you are actually watching that in
real time today for example a couple of
times the president said jumped in and
said I don't like the active shooter
drills I don't like it and he explained
why because he's for children it should
be it would be traumatic and why would
we want to do this to them that's
actually it was very interesting to see
that and you also have a situation where
a president in real time is talking
about ideas that aren't totally fleshed
out
and so when somebody says well but the
NRA is not gonna support that it's like
oh yeah they will and the NRA says well
no actually I don't support that when it
comes to raising the age limit but he's
not afraid to walk over hot coals but
most politicians aren't willing to do to
just say well I'll try that I'm for that
why don't we try that and maybe at the
end of this we'll end up with the bump
stock thing maybe something on the state
level that deals with protecting schools
and hard targets I do think that some of
that has to come from a local level you
get people getting real specific real
quickly the president said what about
giving some of these teachers bonuses if
they are adept at using weapons and they
could be one of these teachers and we
could give them a little bit of bonus
and it's an incentive money immediately
the school board person are there says
yeah could you tell us how we might
actually pay for that because we don't
have any extra money for that and the
president like okay but we'll work on
that later you're actually watching
policymaking in real time rather than
getting it all finished and in a nice
package with a bow and then present it
to the American people so it's
interesting okay good I love the bonus
idea though that was a great idea
exactly but it makes sense right but you
build what did you think Jesse I mean
obviously I know you were very moved as
we all were yesterday and then today was
you know I think significant follow-up
I'm kind of struck by how the Republican
Party is the party of ideas to Greg's
point you've had so many specific ideas
come out from the president's mouth
about solving this issue you've had a
lot of specific ideas coming from the
president's mouth about solving
immigration and we saw the same kind of
organic how the sausage is made kind of
meeting with the immigration thing
you're seeing it with guns now and I'm
not hearing the same sort of ideas
coming from the Democratic side of the
aisle I don't even know what the
Democrats want to do on guns I know they
don't like guns I know they want to ban
ar-15s but besides that in terms of
school safety
what is the Democrats position on school
safety I don't know what it is maybe one
can enlighten me but we've just rattled
off three - four - five six really great
practical ideas
and the president to his credit is
leading his party away from the kind of
strict I'm not going to do anything on
guns stance that they've had in the past
and it's a tired analogy it's the Nixon
goes to China analogy I hate to use it
but it's so appropriate here if anybody
can do something on guns and gun safety
it's going to be President Donald J
Trump it's not like and the Democrats
love to say this the kindergarten
teacher who's 80 years old miss Edelman
is going to be packin a nine-millimeter
on her waist while she teaches you know
one plus one is two
that's a scare tactic he's talking about
janitors or bureaucrats or
administrators or teachers that are
trained and have license have a locked
up weapon so when the alarm goes off
they can go do that I don't see what the
problem is with that the Democrats seem
to want to bend bad guys and good guys
from having weapons I don't understand
why we would ban good guys okay all
right one what did you think about the
last two days now well I think the the
signal event of the last two days is the
young people coming out Kimberly in the
way that they have and becoming a force
in the political discussion about guns
in the aftermath of what took place in
parkland and then the other side of it
that's more fascinating to me in a sad
way is the attacks on the kids that have
come from the right calling them actors
and puppets actors yeah and and and
absolutely belittling young people
because they stand up and say hey this
is impacting our lives
enough s'en up do something I think it
has is a cry that's being heard around
the country now you know to me when you
talk about things like oh let's arm the
schools which is like seems to me the
number one idea coming from President
Trump essentially I think you're
enlisting then in the NRA army because
you're saying everybody has to have guns
we're gonna have to have guns everywhere
even around our children and I think
we're and with the proliferation of guns
in schools I think you can anticipate
there going to be more gun incidents in
schools and to me that's not a good idea
I think what we want to do is speak
clearly the problem is
because of the NRA and its power over
the politicians you get into a situation
like you had last night at the CNN event
where Marco Rubio you know he's saying I
am for lowering the age limit which is
what President Trump is it said with
regard to the guns and people say oh no
you know what about your fixation on the
NRA is your way out of a debate no he
said he's glad to have things let's go
on what we probably buy guys did I said
I think that arming schools is
essentially asking all of us to enlist
in the NRA army to them so we don't we
can't leader Wayne LaPierre offered a
fierce defense of gun rights at CPAC if
they truly cared what they would do is
they would protect them for them it's
not a safety issue it's a political
issue their goal is to eliminate the
Second Amendment in our firearms
freedoms so they can eradicate all
individual freedoms evil must be
confronted immediately with all
necessary force to protect our kids to
stop a bad guy with a gun it takes a
good guy with a gun
okay that was a line Greg that was
well-received by the crowd it's a
well-worn line we've heard this slide
before but it's it's true the few want
an example of what he's talking about
just listen to the police chief last
night and I know we're going to talk
about the CNN Town Hall in the B Block
but government the police sometimes that
police chief can't protect you I mean
they went to that kids house how many
times he you know they had like how many
thirty some-odd instances and and they
booed the NRA
at that Town Hall so what what I learned
when I listened to that police chief is
that a private citizen which is a
security or trained personnel could have
could have stopped this because the
police didn't and that's that's the
thing it's like sometimes government
just can't be there and I go back to
that other statistic that's been used
the
the duration of a gun attack is dictated
by the arrival of a second gun so you
got if you if the guns already there
do the math let me just tell you
something that stood out to me watching
Wayne lap here who I know I thought
Wayne LaPierre at CPAC this is going to
be Wayne LaPierre being feted endorsed
applauded dana loesch was there to
Kimberly I thought this is going to be
their moment cuz this is their crowd at
one point Wayne LaPierre says it's
awfully quiet oh I guess you should be
afraid you know why I think there are
lots of people who identify as
conservatives and gun rights supporters
who are uncomfortable at this moment and
I think that's great I think it's a
Trent you're looking at a transition at
the NRA I think that he is the old face
of the NRA and I think the new Dana lash
is the I believe is the future which you
have a young strong woman who can
articulate it's this idea to young
people and brave enough to go in front
like CNN offered such a great deal to
Dana lash don't come and we'll make fun
of you or come and we'll make fun of you
I agree I want to address something you
said in the beginning you said we are
going to arm the schools that's not
accurate not every teacher gets a gun
they're not going to have like turrets
you know above the school with like
machine guns sweeping the grounds that's
insane and you're saying you're
enlisting them in the NRA army that
that's just rhetoric one if it were one
teacher a trained teacher a weapon to
then use to neutralize a school shooter
before police can get there that's
practical that's safe you feel safer
being protected by weapons when you're
at a football game you're a Ravens game
there's a one police officer armed for
each 1000 fans that's a good ratio so if
you have a high school with a thousand
people you have one armed person that's
not an army from the NRA and the NRA is
being created to be a boogeyman because
if you look at the statistics the NRA
doesn't donate that
much money to politicians compared to
other people they donate less than
unions Wow they donate less than Planned
Parenthood they don't even crack the top
50 in terms of lobbying outfits so
listen I know the NRA is powerful in
your mind but a lot of the politicians
that vote with the NRA are you doing it
because they're beholden because they're
getting a lot of donations you can't buy
a politician for $2,500 they vote with
the Second Amendment because they
beiieve in the Second Amendment I want
to get CNN
well I'm just gonna bring up one other
thing which is the possible things that
are changing one of them has to do with
something that's been sort of a thorn in
the side of a lot of people for a long
time especially on the left is that the
CDC the Center for Disease Control
because of an amendment that was passed
25 years ago it has not been allowed and
has not been funded to study gun
violence and mental illness and gun
violence and all of those things get
botched up so one of the things we've
talked about here is that it's better to
make decisions based on evidence and
facts and research so that you can be
logical about it and actually try to
solve the right problem well there's
been changes now it looks like the at
least the Secretary of Health and Human
Services the new one Alex a czar looks
like he's willing he said in a hearing
last week to look at this issue put some
money towards it and even the person
it's called the Dickey amendment former
congressman Dickey is actually thinking
I didn't mean for this to actually
happen over 25 years I would I'm okay
with having some research done so it
might be a small thing but if you are
wanting to make decisions based on
research then there might be a way
forward Dana do you know why that is
it's because of the power of the dollars
that's from the NRA that has shut that
down and made it a political issue
questions about it all the time but
obviously not that powerful because
they're not open to doing it well I mean
25 years that's how that's how difficult
it is Greg sighs let's have real ideas
and real conversations I am so for it
but I think exactly the opposite view I
think it's shut down by people who are
fearful of the inner president Bob I
remember somebody named President Obama
who had a Democratic Senate and
Democratic Congress they had 60
5:45 majority in the Senate they voted
on the assault weapons ban 16 Democrats
voted against it right 9 are still in
the Senate and they're I'm just saying
people are fearful of the of having an
honest you say people when it's Democrat
no no I think totally in lock to the NRA
and some Democrats are very fearful that
if they say anything they will be still
suffer at the ballot I think you guys
create this in your head so you don't
have to actually give practical
solutions that allow law-abiding gun
owners to have their guns so you create
this big like we can't do anything we're
paralyzed so you can't actually you
can't actually listen to the practical
solutions that have been laid before you